the raider is opening training camp this
week and it's going to be a busy time
out in henderson
kevin martin joining us now with a
preview kevin well thanks denise the
raiders report to camp tomorrow and will
officially
take the field for the first time on
wednesday vegas finished with an 8-8
record last season
and come into this season with a lot to
build on specifically on offense
finishing in the top 10 last year
and they have most of their key players
returning but they need to get more out
of their defense they gave up
30 points a game and that just won't cut
it in the nfl but with the new defensive
coordinator in place gus bradley
there's some optimism heading into the
season on that side of the ball
i don't think it's a secret we were
pretty good on offense last year and we
weren't very good on defense so
the goal is to get a little bit better
on offense and get a lot better on
defense
coach gruden and i are on the same page
we think we've got a young
aggressive tough football team and we
can't wait to see if they can measure up
the battle begins on wednesday they've
got a lot of new faces on defense this
year and as i mentioned of course the
new coordinators so they've got to learn
a new system in a hurry and the silver
and black open their preseason in less
than
three weeks against seattle here at home
first regular season game is september
13th on monday night football
also at allegiant stadium against the
baltimore ravens
brian